[Music]
my name is Dina champion
I don't have anything I would say I am
laid-back fun and a little bit eccentric
at times I started by making my own
clothes at home wearing them in a mini
photo shoot and then poking the pictures
onto my favorite things and then my
Facebook audience said hey you should
really show us how to wear your hair
cool so we want to know how I need to do
on YouTube and I was like wow okay I
never thought I would ever be sitting in
front of the camera filming with them
but then I did it because that's what
they wanted and I guess I never thought
I see it as a very positive future I
feel like finally people learn as a
singer and recognizing our effort let's
say and putting us in the right place in
the fashion world effective citizen
[Music]
I think the rise of modest fashion has
been a long time coming
I started blogging seven years ago and
that was my aim to see to make it kind
of like a movement and now people are
really taking notice of it and for me
that's the most positive outcome I think
it's great thing in general but then for
a fashion house to design something
that's already what we kind of have it
just very disappointing because we don't
want what we already have we want what
you are known for
but adapted to our needs so we don't
want cultural appropriation you want
your design with long sleeves longer
notes and Bill Hyneman
[Music]
not many people know but I used to be
quite overweight and have a eating
disorder when I was younger
but they gotta play Baccarat the best
thing about kids my husband is that he
is incredibly supportive and if without
support I really wouldn't be able to
tell you engine wandering I would say 16
year-old Deena not to over pluck your
eyebrows as much as needed and I would
say don't stress so much about what
you're going to do for a living because
if you do what you love then it will
work and you can make it happen just
make sure you end up doing what you
really genuinely love doing my greatest
fears are that my daughter will grow up
in a society where she can't be herself
she can't express a view and she can't
live her religion
I hope I will maybe have a team orchid
no slow exchanger maybe just one more
kid and hopefully be very stable in my
career whether that be carrying on
blogging or grunting on TV or building
you can move or the ultimate dream of
having a clothing line of doing nothing
but I don't think about it too much
that's what I look like so this is
American power for more videos like
these then make sure you subscribe to
glamour UK down below and if you want to
see more of my videos then you can head
over to my channel but make sure you
subscribe to glamour UK